[Music]
here on the snowy slopes of mount hood
oregon it seems impossible that the u.s
could ever run low on water
but government-backed research says we
could in little more than 50 years
[Music]
oregon relies heavily on snowmelt for
its fresh water but when the winter
snows fail
it can cause severe water shortages in
the summer and those snows
are failing more
today i've come to the city of portland
to meet kyle anderson
lead architect of haslow and eighth an
innovative housing development
where technology is helping to
significantly reduce residents water
footprint
the one thing about this project what
makes it really unique is that we had
the opportunity to have critical mass
you know to take three acres of asphalt
and bring on a million square feet of
657 apartments
all of a sudden the demand for the
resources becomes much higher
so the savings become that much higher
as well
and so talk to me about the red tanks
this is the norm system
so norm is an acronym for natural
organic recycling machine
this development treats all black and
gray water on site for the residents
we basically are harvesting water all of
the apartments for flushing toilets for
watering gardens
we're treating 45 000 gallons of
black and gray water daily
[Music]
and then we just celebrate it it becomes
part of the vernacular of the
architecture
we call it science on display actually
drove
people to this development as we build
more and more and we get denser and
denser
this is going to become more and more
important maybe we should be approaching
infrastructure in a different way
there are a lot of simple and accessible
technologies that have been put into
this building
that we can use in all our homes
good to see you talk to me a little bit
about the water saving features in the
building
we have compact four gallon dishwashing
system
the low flow shower the front loading
washers and dryers you didn't think
about all these sustainable things but
they're already just built in for you
sustainability by design right and it's
becoming like the new norm
but many homes in the u.s still use
standard top-loading washing machines
that can use around 45 gallons of water
per load but front loaders use as little
as 13
and many of us still rinse our dirty
dishes under a running faucet before
loading them into the dishwasher
this is a huge waste of water because
you actually need the dishes to be dirty
as the enzymes and the detergent latch
onto food particles to work effectively
it's these small actions done by house
builders and homeowners across america
that can add up to big water savings
and that can make a huge difference to
our nation's water security
[Music]